- I have these slippers
in like four different colors.
- Yeah.
- I live in them.
- I quit on heels.
I'm done.
Six months pregnant and
no more heels. We're done.
- I'm not even pregnant
and I'm not wearing heels!
- Yeah. Over it.
Anytime I can cheat with my stylist,
I'm like wouldn't a boot be great?
- Why do we have to wear heels?
- A nice flat boot?
- I HATE 'EM.
- Congratulations on baby number 2!
- Dude, I made another one!
- "I made another one!
- So you have a new song
out now called Mother.
I actually talked to Scott Wing about it.
And Kris Jenner's in the video, right?
- Yeah.
- All right!
So what, how did that happen?
- I prayed and I, we were
like spit balling ideas.
I was like, I don't want
it to be another video
of me doing a full choreo going out there.
I'm pregnant. No one knew.
And I was like,
How funny and iconic
and amazing would it be
if I actually got Kris
Jenner in the video?
- Yeah.
- And I've, I've learned-
- Looking fantastic!
Looking like a beauty queen.
Both of you look so beautiful.
- She's so perfect.
And I, it was one of those,
we giggled when I thought of the idea,
'cause we're like, there's
no way she'll say yes.
Like, she's so busy.
And we're like, well the worst
thing you could do is ask
- Yeah.
- And the worst thing is a no,
and we'll figure it out. And she said Yes.
The day before my birthday.
And I was sobbing.
- That's so cool!
- I was like, this is the
best birthday of my life!
So Megan, your new book is
called Dear Future Mama.
- Come here my boy!
- Look at that.
- That's literally,
we tried to a photo shoot for an hour
and he was just running away
and I was like, come back!
- Which is exactly-
- We were like, that's it! That explains,
that's how I felt.
- If you wanna know what
parenting will look like.
- Yes. Grabbing them from-
- Run away!
- You know, dying.
And doing things they shouldn't.
No, you can't fly like Peter Pan!
- Yeah.
- So what inspired you to write this?
Why'd you wanna do this?
- I felt so alone.
I was 26 and none of my
friends were even married,
so I was alone in that way.
I didn't have a bestie
to go through it with.
But also it was COVID times
and so I couldn't like
leave the house, you know?
- Real lonely.
- Yeah. So I was ALONE.
and my besties became YouTubers, you know?
I was just online every day,
from how to get knocked up to like,
what do I pack in my bag?
- Did you need help on
how to get knocked up?
- Yes. You'd be surprised.
- Okay. Okay.
- I found some tricks and tips.
- Okay.
- And it worked!
You ovulate for like one
12-hour period or something.
And it's science and magic.
And if you don't hit that then
you're just wasting time...
or having fun.
- I have found- "or having fun!"
- It became like a job.
You know, we're gonna get it done!
- Get in here, I got 12 hours!
- I wanted to become that YouTuber,
but in a nice book with pictures
for everyone out there.
I could be your bestie and be like
this is how it worked and whatever.
- I love that.
- I have an amazing-
sorry I have to say this
or else I'll forget.
I have an amazing dietician and a trainer
and my OBGYN is in this book
giving tips and tricks.
And my "hubband".
- I love- Dr. Crow is my OBGYN. I love-
You become so connected with them
and they are a resource!
- I'm like, you guys should write books.
And I'm like, I'll do it for you!
Just get in mine.
- Yeah.
- I can text her like
the most random questions
and she's just the greatest girl ever
and gives me all her time and attention
and I trust her with my life.
- I'm gonna tell you,
I not only texted mine
during the whole thing,
I mean she probably was like
I cannot believe I gave
this person my number.
- I know!
- But also Dr. Donna
Crow- sorry, shout out!
But I would send pictures.
- Oh yeah!
- I'm like, so is this normal?
- I just sent her pictures
of my veins in my legs.
I was like, something's going on.
- I sent her pictures...
- Oh, down there?
- Just of things, just things
that would happen sometimes.
And I'm like, does this mean like,
is everything intact?
Like when it's happening.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I've sent like some strange things...
- Because they don't tell you that!
This book's very TMI.
You will get some-
- I love TMI!
I want it broken down.
I want it real blunt.
- Yes. And that's what
you get with this book.
- I like that.
I don't think we'd expect
anything differently
from you which I love, yeah.
So did you find any misinformation
when you were researching?
Like, did people give you tips
that you tried and were like, no.
- (with accent) Yes.
- I love that sometimes
you become Scottish!
- Yesssss.
So there's not like, there
wasn't like crazy misinformation.
It was just like some things work out,
some things don't work.
- I love that you're willing to try.
- Yeah. Like what to bring
in your hospital bag.
Some girls were like,
bring all your makeup
and four outfits to change.
I was like, I was in that
hospital rag like daily.
I was like, we don't need to change it.
This one's fine.
You know?
- Yeah. If I smell,
just don't get near me.
- Yeah.
So Megan, everyone knows
that you like to keep
it real on social media
and life in general.
So can you explain what's
going on in this video
your brother shot?
- (Meghan) Oh, I'm shaving
my beard! My peach!
- Here's- oh, you cut yourself.
- Listen, I'm not good at it.
He made me nervous!
He started filming me outta nowhere.
I was doing Australian Idol.
I was a judge and I-
- People don't talk about this.
Let's talk about it.
- I'm fuzzy-wuzzy.
- So peach fuzz, right?
- Yeah.
- The older you get, children...
Literally I'm like,
I am a peach right now.
- Yes.
- Like I have so much and I'm blonde.
- And I'm blonde, yeah.
So then when I go in
the sun, it looks like
I'm a Twilight vampire.
'Cause I glisten! My beard will glisten.
- I saw it in the "Lips
are Movin'" music video.
They wee like, we're gonna
do a closeup on your lips.
I was like, (accent) I have a mustache!
Like, why didn't no one tell me?
And so on big important days-
- Peach fuzz!
- I'll shave when I know
we're doing a music video
I will shave the night
before and the day of.
I shaved out there with
a new razor-type thing
and I sliced myself
and my brother's like,
(accent) oh boy, you know?
He was like, this isn't
good. You're on TV tonight.
- I literally have to, yeah,
I don't do it 'cause I'm lazy.
But my, my girl Glow does
and I always make the joke.
I always make the joke.
I'm like, are you gonna
gonna shave my beard?
Is that what we're doing right now?
- Yeah.
And I'm like, cause
there's so much peach fuzz.
- And you have to get all of it
or else there's like a line.
- It's like, yeah, it's like
a line of glistening blonde-
- My makeup artist is
like what have you done?
I was like, did I miss a spot?
She's like mm-hmm.
- I know!
And it always catches the
sun like the perfect...
Yeah. Anyway.
- That's real, we're hairy.
- Super attractive.
At least it's blonde.
- At least it's blonde. It's like, yeah.
- We're lucky.
- All right, let's do another break.
Megan's book Dear Future
Mama is available today
wherever books are sold
and everyone in our audience
is leaving with their own copy!
We have another video from social
'cause we just love your social account.
- Aw, precious.
- We need your husband here
to talk about it though.
So everybody please welcome Megan's hubby,
Daryl Sabar!
Come on Daryl!
I love the video!
Come on over.
I love this video.
But first off, how's Riley doing?
- He's great.
We were gonna bring him today
but he like is doing the
two-month molars teething.
- Two years.
- Oh, two years.
- So he won't nap.
And he's like, "fwustwated."
- I love Bluey!
My kids love Bluey too.
I was actually coloring
with my son last night-
Oh my God!
- He's in an airplane/rocket
phase right now.
- I would snuggle so hard with that one!
So let's see this video though.
So Darryl posted it and
it, this is his impression-
- Oh God.
- Of pregnant Megan.
- Did you call for ice?
- No.
- I knew you wouldn't call for ice.
Can I see one pillow?
I'm so uncomfortable.
- You have to watch the whole video.
It's a whole thing!
- It is a lot.
It's hilarious.
- I just recommend that when you're
gonna make the video
you have to make it with
your significant other.
- I have to be there.
- I was like, I did not sound like that.
- They had to get approval first.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Before you post anything.
- Yes.
Is this pretty accurate, this video?
- Yeah. (accent) I complain a lot.
- That was me at the end too.
And I was like, get it out!
- Get it out.
- I have to say though,
you haven't revealed
the gender of your second baby yet.
- We revealed our first one on your show!
- I know, so I was wondering
if you'd do it again.
- I was like, let's do it again!
- I like it!
- Okay, let's get a
little, I'm so excited!
Okay, let's get a little help
from our friend from above,
the voice of God,
because he knows things.
He knows these things.
Are you there, Lord?
(celestial music)
- (God) Why yes I am, Kelly.
Hello, Megan and Darryl.
- Hi.
Or should I say Juni? I'm sorry.
I'm a big Spy Kids fan!
Oh, I just love Spy Kids.
Oh, you were such a
cute little guy in that!
Fingers crossed for the reboot!
Anyway, sorry about that Kelly.
- Fingers crossed. Here's
the thing, actually,
I wasn't gonna bring it up.
My kids are obsessed with it.
- Really?
- My kids are obsessed with it.
- He'll FaceTime whenever!
- I'm not kidding.
Like, they would die!
They'd be like, you know him!
Like I'm not kidding.
So wait, so we were
hoping since you know all
you could maybe reveal the gender
of Megan and Daryl's second child.
- What am I having?
- (God) Yes, I do know all.
I mean, I was there for the conception.
So, you know, not in a weird
way, not in a weird way.
I'm everywhere.
It is all about that bass!
So I would be happy to bless this moment
with my vast and infinite knowledge.
Are y'all ready for this?
- Yes!
(audience whoops)
- Okay. And the gender
of this child shall be
(explosion)
- I'm sorry about that,
that's the wrong button.
I pressed the wrong button.
I'm sorry.
You know what?
Let, let's hear the gender reveal
from Big Brother Riley.
You know what, let's do it.
- 3, 2, 1...
It's a boy!
(audience cheers)
- Oh my god!
I love that Riley did it!